are women better drivers than men and
i'm sitting there saying this guy's
actually making the argument and he's
serious about it he says well yeah women
are better drivers than men according to
data data sometimes lies what do you
mean by that
first of all
okay
so
let's let's talk about a couple
different things when it comes down to
why insurance is cheaper for women than
it is for men number one who in their
lifetime drives more miles men or women
who drives more miles is it even a
question well if you're gonna include
truckers
not this man but i'm saying like most
men nobody's ubered more than me around
here most men drive more miles than
women do okay second statistics if we
were to take the average
speed men go versus the average speed
women go how many more miles per hour do
you think men go than women probably
probably i was going to say 10 miles
right okay if you're going 10 miles
faster than women dude the chance of you
get into an accident it's probably if
it's 50 miles 10 20 percent higher of
you killing yourself and car accident